the White House is moving to curb the
vaping epidemic in America that's linked
to at least six recent deaths now a new
initiative would ban most flavored
cigarettes allowing only tobacco flavor
the FDA says it could also cut down on
those devices if the number of minors
using them Rises the new guidelines are
due to be rolled out and next several
weeks and companies would have 30 days
to comply cases of possible vaping
related illnesses have been reported in
at least 36 states including Hawaii
Idaho and Washington which just reported
their first cases this week the CDC says
it's looking into more than 450 possible
cases overall the National Youth tobacco
survey says more than 3 million high
school students used e-cigarettes last
year in the United States CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus is
with us doctor we declare public health
emergencies and in fact the Trump
administration did when it came to
opioids sometimes hurricanes also get
that treatment is it time with east
cigarettes to declare an emergency
well that three million number you
reference at the White House yesterday
they say it's 5 million this year and so
you know kids are getting nicotine and
THC in their brain that's still
developing and we're not we don't know
what it does you know in order to get
the nicotine or the THC from this
e-cigarette into your lungs it needs a
carrier molecule so heat supplied a
carrier malkov goes in and it stays in
the lung hence the lung disease and the
potential deaths I mean in the deaths
that are happening around the country we
need to step up here because we don't
know the implications
how long before we will know I mean it
took us it took us a long time to figure
out what cigarettes would do couple of
decades where doctors is saying hey
smoke camels it's good for you and a
couple of decades and we say hey it
caused lung cancer we are experimenting
on this generation 5 million kids are
being experimented on in schools today
we have to step up for companies to
continue to sell flavored East
cigarettes the Trump administration has
said they would have to prove its a net
good for public health in other words it
helps adults more than it hurts kids do
you think they can meet that threshold
no I I don't think there's even closer
and I think this companies are smart and
they're gonna keep pushing what they're
pushing tobacco flavor and unflavored
jewel
or other east cigarettes as a vehicle
hopefully to prevent smoking but the
ramifications of this on a health basis
we just don't know the way our country
works is you put it out there and then
we see what it does over years and then
we make a decision go backwards hey
maybe we shouldn't be doing this
maybe the policy should be reversed well
they've been around a long time now the
e-cigarettes why did it take the FDA so
long to get authority over them I've
been on the market for like at least 10
years yeah they came from in the early
2000s a pharmacist in China actually
came up with the modern-day e-cigarette
they've been around for a long time they
weren't under the jurisdiction of the
FDA until 2016 and then since they've
been under their jurisdiction the FDA
hasn't yet stepped up aggressively in
terms of regulating why they under FDA
jurisdiction till 2016 the Congress has
to say what FDA regulates so tobacco
went under the FDA and then years later
these cigarettes did but we don't know
the outcome is the problem so the
company said hey listen this is a
vehicle to stop smoking stopping smoking
is good in our country we're seeing
smoking rights go down all of a sudden
vaping rates goes up you know a year ago
I interviewed Ned Sharples who's now act
acting FDA commissioner who's head of
the National Cancer and I said what
keeps you up at night you know being
head of the National Cancer suit and he
said three words they think they Bing
baby Wow as a doctor do you see any
benefits at all to vaping we know right
now that taking our we've been doing
that has lower lung cancer rates than
smokers there's no evidence that it has
lower emphysema than smokers there's
evidence that it's a gateway for
children to go to real tobacco products
also
doctor I guess the American Cancer
Society says that cigarettes are
markedly less harmful than traditional
cigarettes but that is not based on data
we don't have long-term data on
e-cigarettes yet so you can't make such
a statement you could say maybe it is we
should do the studies we just don't know
the answer yet so two people so bad as
cigarettes I think they can be as bad as
cigarettes yes so there's no benefit to
being weaned off cigarettes onto
e-cigarettes
well the benefit is to being weaned off
to nothing if C cigarettes is a way to
taper down your smoking then maybe
there's a positive there but again the
maybe
is there we just don't know the answer
and so listen I'm data-driven most times
we have technology that we think will do
something in health we turn out to be
wrong I hope it's not the case here but
there isn't data that I'm aware of that
it is safer than tobacco in the long run
well it's hard for me to tell how you
feel no thank you what you believe I
also agree with that
thank you dr. agus